our economic and data editor Ed Conway
has been speaking to the bank's Governor
Andrew Bailey I know it's very difficult
for families I think it's you know
understand that
we have raised rates by by half percent
today because you know we've obviously
still got a very high level of inflation
I do see the signs that we're turning
the corner and that obviously is
encouraging but there's a long way to go
under some very big risks out there
which could throw us back off course and
cause inflation to be higher than we
think but
we have very deliberately changed the
language that we've used today
so we have been in recent times using
language which we did say if the economy
evolves as we think it is I'm afraid
there are going to be further rate Rises
we have not used that language today and
that's important yeah we're going to
take it
you know each game each game as it comes
as it were and look at the evidence so
closely as we do and see what we
conclude from that for the path of
inflation for people you know who are
looking people who have mortgages who
are looking and seeing those rates going
up and just trying to make their own
plans and they're worried that they're
going to head up higher and higher and
higher yeah you'll message them as maybe
you don't need to be quite as panicky as
you might have been I'm hoping that we
will see as we have done in recent
months much more stability and the
interest rates curve off which mortgages
are priced by the way I know this is for
new mortgages rather than obviously
people whose mortgages reset
automatically actually mortgage rates
have come down over the last couple of
months and that's important I was I was
hoping back in November that they would
and and we have seen reference to that
but I realize that evidence is helpful
but there are a lot of people of course
who don't immediately benefit from that
you have your kind of you know your
finger on the pulse when it comes to
inflation when it comes to wage
inflation all these pressures coming in
and you say that maybe we're now turning
the corner on on inflation so that's
that's a big deal does it not follow
them that you know some of this pressure
on public sector wages that the
government has been trying to keep down
you know is that really still necessary
given that we have turned that corner
well I would say that the biggest risk
we Face are to the problem going forward
is both price and wage setting by the
way because they're both important now
just picking those two up on price
setting by firms I go around the country
a lot a lot of firms are now saying to
me they are finding it more difficult to
pass through increased costs so we may
see some I mean alleviation on that
front
weight setting certainly in the private
sector wave setting has overshot what we
thought it would be so we are concerned
about that and when we do look at the
whole economy and that you know what
happens going forwards on on Wave
setting will be very important and we
will be watching it very closely uh
because that will be a I think an
important indicator of whether this very
sharp downward path of inflation will
happen